hey youtubers is Charlie remember that
time that Harley Quinn got to wield a
Green Lantern ring and use Wonder
Woman's lasso in Batman used a sword
well they're getting ready for a big
Justice League versus Suicide Squad
story so I'm gonna do an explainer for
their epic battles in the movies and in
the comics there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out on anything so
Justice League vs The Suicide Squad we
got like a little taste of that in the
Suicide Squad movie especially with the
end tag Bruce Wayne talking about his
team he's putting together I'm gonna
play this montage then I'll explain how
killer frost is on the team in what's
going on with a big Justice League vs
Suicide Squad rebirth event and what
they're doing with Deathstroke in the
movies there's also some really cool
news about the Justice League trailer
I'll explain at the end of this it's
over Deadshot I wanna do this order
daddy Zoe knew that was just the
beginning
we have God company that
she's crazier than him and more fearless
that's running
but the bet got her too
she's in the same homeless deadshot
[Music]
no honor among thieves a this is crown
jewels here mr. Wayne and you do
understand my legal exposure if anyone
knew what I procured for you listen I
can keep a secret okay what do you want
people are asking questions about Midway
city the kind of people can get the
answers and then they can get those
answers my head will be on a pike
consider yourself under my protection
if you deliver
[Music]
why miss Jolene just like to make
friends
the difference between those who believe
in friendship I believe in the leverage
goodnight you look tired we should stop
working nights you should shut it down
my friends and I'll do it for you but
the next big time they will face off
will be that Gotham City sirens Harley
Quinn movie that'll be more of a Harley
Quinn movie though not like a giant
team-up like they're getting ready to do
in the comics there have been a couple
times that they've crossed over but
Geoff Johns was teasing that they're
making this Justice League versus
Suicide Squad comic book event a huge
rebirth tent pole that's debuting this
month so in the rebirth universe nobody
knows that the Suicide Squad exists that
roster is actually pretty close to the
movie the one big change is that they
put killer frost the Caitlin snow killer
frost on the team and this is a way more
hardcore version than the one on the TV
show the one of the TV show is kind of
like a proto killer frost she's almost
there and you've seen her in the costume
fighting Cisco this past season it was a
flash-forward but it was still freakin
badass please I just need to know for
sure I need to know if I become evil
because if I do I have to leave and
never come back
see
[Music]
how's the leg sorry Caitlin that was
cold flash
but the current rebirth roster is Harley
Quinn the Caitlin snow killer frost of
course el Diablo Captain Boomerang Rick
Flagg enchantress Deadshot and Killer
Croc in a relatively similar setup to
what the movie was like they're so
relatively early in the life of the team
but then Batman finds out about it flash
Aquaman and even Superman are like oh
hell no so nobody likes the ideas of
their enemies getting a free Hall Pass
for doing some questionable work for the
government on the down low so the
Suicide Squad is still trying to do
something good they find out about
someone called apex with a death cult
that's going to sacrifice an entire
island to their god
so what brand-new Suicide Squad is
brought in to take them down but then
later they've been teasing this art like
Harley Quinn holding Wonder Woman's
lasso obviously that's probably not
gonna happen in the comic but it just
teases the idea that you have these two
epic teams going against each other some
will be split down the middle and the
villains will end up fighting with the
heroes to defeat somebody that's way
worse arguably this death God that apex
is worshipping so if you couldn't tell
the art is actually from the same person
that did Darkseid war and you can
imagine anti-monitor
versus Darkseid so if they're making
this Justice League versus Suicide Squad
one of the big cornerstones of rebirth
then they're gonna have to have some
huge villains surface the Joker toxin
that Harley name drops here is actually
from a 1980s issue where Joker mixed a
bunch of chemicals from a janitor's
closet to escape from Arkham so just
like flash rebirth or Batman rebirth
they reference things that happen from
before flashpoint they bring that back
into the continuity while at the same
time rebooting things and sort of
starting again so this is like a brand
new Suicide Squad team the first time
they did something like this they
crossed over Justice League and Suicide
Squad was back in 1988 it was more of
like a moral contrast between the two
teams but it only lasted for two issues
is Justice League International number
13 so it's not the standard Justice
League roster that you might remember in
Suicide Squad number 13 one of the
former members of the Suicide Squad
Nemesis gets left behind on
a mission to Russia so both teams decide
to go in and save him so this is a very
Cold War era
remember it was written in the 1980s so
the Cold War with the Soviet Union was
still pretty hardcore so you have Batman
and Rick Flagg bringing their teams
together to go in and extract their man
but the story was really meant to bring
out the best and worst of all the
character so you get the best in the
worst of Batman the best in the worst of
The Suicide Squad it was a really good
opportunity to shed some new light on
the characters in the Justice League
because you think Justice League and you
think that they're morally above
everyone they always make the right
decision but this team was a little bit
different they had c-listers like
Booster Gold Blue Beetle on the team it
was a very different time for the
Justice League so putting them in a
Suicide Squad story just allowed the
writers to have some more fun with
characters that normally had to walk the
tightrope of morality but what they're
probably going to be doing in the DC
movies is just having minor crossovers I
wouldn't expect a full-blown Justice
League versus Suicide Squad movie at
least until after the second Justice
League movie like they had the first big
team-up they come together
Superman resurfaces in between they have
a couple run-ins with each of their
minor villains that end up being part of
the Suicide Squad they themselves have
another adventure
and then finally Amanda Waller orders a
hit on the Justice League so one of the
things I felt like the movie actually
did really well was paint the Amanda
Waller character as being the real
villain of the story like enchantress
was the villain that they had to take
down but really Amanda Waller came away
feeling like the antagonist like no
matter how bad the villains are there's
still some honor amongst thieves but
they been hyping the [ __ ] out of this
all year and Jim Lee has been working on
Suicide Squad so I feel like if there
are any comics that you're looking to
pick up Suicide Squad would actually be
a good place to start but this is gonna
be its own separate thing Justice League
versus Suicide Squad
just like Justice League dark side war
was kind of its own miniseries so if you
really like the art from Dark Side war
and you want to see Batman and Superman
kick the [ __ ] out of the Suicide Squad
first issue dropping this Wednesday so
if you guys want me to do like a full
comic book story video for it just let
me know in the comments but as
for big movie characters obviously you
know about the Harley Quinn movie that I
just did a video about there's a
Deadshot movie that they're doing for
Will Smith that might not turn into an
actual thing for a couple years but they
did announce it and then we have
Deathstroke who was also a member of the
Suicide Squad who was going to be part
of the new Batman movie and Justice
League Deathstroke himself is a bit more
of a question mark in the movie universe
right now because he could totally go to
the Suicide Squad the rumor right now is
that he's been hired by Lex Luthor who
is still in prison to kill the Batman in
depending on where the movie leaves him
I do think that he'll show back up again
during the solo Batman movie I think
he'd be a perfect villain for Deadshot
to face off against because that'd be
good opportunity to put Deadshot on the
side of the heroes for once usually you
want to have him go back and forth a
little bit let me know we're gonna have
a ton of Justice League characters
fighting Suicide Squad characters in the
movies do you ever want to see him do a
full-blown event like this big comic
book event they're doing in related news
if you want me to do a Superman vs
Deathstroke video they just had an epic
battle just let me know in the comments
but they're supposedly going to be a
Justice League trailer soon everyone
kind of thought that it was gonna drop
around Christmas time so that might
still happen Zack Snyder was saying that
it's coming really really soon but he
couldn't specify when just making it
sound like yeah it's right around the
corner so prepare for justice leaked
trailer craziness - will you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
watch the flash fight iris West and you
can click here to watch spider-man turn
into Deadpool and Deadpool turn into
spider-man thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight